هذه الصور
المتداوله الفيديو المتداول لانهيار عدد
من الابنيه فوق
الساكنيها في مدينه سرمدا بيري في ادلب
السوري جراء الزلزال الذي ضرب شمال سوريا
وجنوب تركيا صبيحه هذا اليوم وهو مع ساعات
الفجر الاولى اذا هذه صور متداوله وفيديو
متداول لانهيار عدد من الابنيه نشاهدها
الان واياكم على شاشه العربيه فوق ساكنها
في مدينه سرمدا بريف ادلب جرار الزلزال
الذي ذكرنا بانه قد ضرب سوريا وتركيا
اليوم زلزال بقوه سبعه فاصله ثمان درجات
على مقياس ريختر اكثر من 500 قتيل حتى
الان الاف الاصابات والاف المشردين ايضا
التي تتحدث عنهم الاحصاءات حتى هذه اللحظه
اعود اليكم مره اخرى جمعه كنت تتحدث عن
الامكانيات القلي مقارنه بحجم هذه
الكارثه في الشمال السوري